2023 is a massive year for RPGs from new
IP from beloved Studios to remakes and
ports of some of the biggest games in
the genre these are the biggest RPGs
coming out in 2023 and Beyond important
to note these games cover the massive
scale of the RPG genre from action RPGs
to more traditional turn-based games so
don't worry your Soul's likes are on
this list
[Music]
experience the world of the Harry Potter
books and films like never before in
this action RPG from Avalanche software
and WB Games get sorted into your house
tame magical beasts craft potions and
spells and become the witch or wizard
that you are destined to be in this
massive open world explore Hogwarts in
the 1800s not only the castle itself but
the immense open grounds surrounding it
including the Forbidden Forest and
hogsmead ride your broom or a magical
Beast like a hippogriff or thestral as
you fight trolls goblins and dark
Wizards to unlock the secrets of an
ancient evil magic discover the
mysteries of the Wizarding World when
Hogwarts Legacy Launches on PS5 and Xbox
series X and S on February 10th PS4 and
Xbox One on April 4th and switch on July
25th 2023
the First new IP from Bethesda Studios
in 25 years Starfield takes all the
elements fans know and love from games
like Fallout and the Elder Scrolls and
transports them to distant galaxies in
the far future in the year 2330 you
begin your journey as a minor with
constellation the final band of
explorers searching the Galaxy for rare
artifacts from humble beginnings you'll
be able to travel to and explore over a
thousand unique planets fighting and
navigating as you try to unlock the
mysteries of the universe how will your
journey unravel find out when Starfield
Launches on PC and Xbox in 2023
Lilith has returned to Sanctuary will
you drive out the darkness or let chaos
Reign Slaughter demons explore the
massive open world of sanctuary plunge
into vast and unrelenting Dungeons and
of course acquire the most legendary
loot the battle between Heaven and Hell
rages on when Diablo 4 Launches on all
systems on 6 6 2023
two of the biggest titles in the Persona
series are finally getting revitalized
for modern consoles Persona 3 Portable
and Persona 4 Golden although Persona 4
Golden has been released more widely on
Steam recently this is the first time
Persona 3 Portable will be playable
outside of its PSP and Vita releases if
you've played Persona 5 you'll be
familiar with the moment-to-moment
gameplay of Persona 3 and 4. develop
your Social Links and interact with the
day-to-day activities of your school
while also entering Twisted Dungeons and
otherworldly Dimensions to fight
monsters Persona 3 Portable also has
dual protagonists the only time this has
ever been a feature in the series
allowing you to choose a male or female
option for your main character that will
affect how you move through your
day-to-day both games launch on all
systems on January 18th 2023
Final Fantasy VII rebirth continues the
heralded tale of cloud and Company from
Final Fantasy VII remake and will cover
the middle chapter of the Final Fantasy
VII story not much is known about the
project but game director tetsuya namura
has stated that development is
progressing rapidly in the final entry
in the trilogy is already in development
rebirth is expected on Playstation
between winter 2023 to early 2024.
the next installment in the storied
series final fantasy 16 features
fast-paced magic and swordplay with a
combat system developed by Devil May Cry
and Dragon's Dogma veteran ryota Suzuki
the story follows the life of Clive
rossfield the son of an Archduke spread
across the different seasons of his life
and the ever-changing political dramas
and conflicts between his and other
kingdoms throughout the realm in
contrast to Final Fantasy XV the world
is not open to explore but will feature
large explorable areas throughout the
linear progression of Clive's tale dive
into the Might and Magic of Final
Fantasy 16 expected to launch on
Playstation in the summer of 2023.
lies of P puts you in the mechanized
shoes of Pinocchio fighting through the
19th century inspired city of krat on a
quest to find Geppetto the only hope to
become fully human is to trust no one
and lie to as many people as possible
each quest line is procedurally
generated depending on how you choose to
lie and the domino effect of the choices
that stem from those lies gameplay is
set firmly within the soul genre with
Perry's Dodges and swordplay all
prominent means of taking out your
enemies weapons can be combined to make
even deadlier Contraptions along with
using augments on your physical form to
give you the edge in battle I'm very
excited to explore the city of krat in
its late 19th to early 20th century
Aesthetics similar to the Aesthetics in
BioShock Infinite or bloodborne lies of
p is set to release on all systems in
2023
continuing the 2.5 D style of the first
game the beautiful world of octopath
traveler 2 comes to life with 8 new
travelers to forge an all-new Adventure
each character of your eight-person
party has their unique motivations
skills and origin stories explore the
dynamic world of Celestia full of
diverse cultures and a day night cycle
that constantly affects the world around
you fans of the mechanics of the
original octopath traveler need not
worry you can still develop your party
members skills and jobs and use the
break and boost system during battles
octopath traveler 2 Launches on all
systems on February 24th 2023
play as The Monkey King himself in the
new action RPG from developer game
science black myth Wukong aims to take
on the massive tale of the Journey to
the West use The Monkey King's iconic
staff as well as Elemental and even
transformation abilities to fight Fierce
enemies including dragons spiders and
demons test your might when blackmyth
Wukong launches in 2023
the sequel to The acclaimed Dungeon
Crawler continues the exploration of the
stresses of adventuring both mental and
physical instead of exploring Mass
dungeons 500 feet below the ground
darkest dungeon 2 puts your band of
adventurers on a massive road trip
however this is no pleasure Cruise the
road has hordes of monsters that will
attack with famine and disease with each
encounter gradually picking at the
mental fortitude of your party members
what will your adventure cost find out
when darkest dungeon 2 launches in 2023
wo long Fallen Dynasty is the latest
game from Neo creators team ninja based
on the old Guan zhong's novel Romance of
the Three Kingdoms wulong is an action
RPG set in China just before the start
of the Three Kingdoms period part of the
character creation includes choosing the
specific phase or combat style you want
to start with these are used to decide
which spells you start with your stats
and which Divine Beast will join you in
your fight instead of katana wielding
action like Neo wallong will be based on
traditional martial arts and weapon
rearranging from glaves swords staffs
and more rack up hits against your
opponent's Spirit meter a la sakuro to
break their posture and deliver the
finishing blow become the hero of three
kingdoms China when woh long Fallen
Dynasty Launches on all systems on March
3rd 2023
[Music]
become one of the legendary dark
Crusaders and quests to defeat adir the
demon god in Lords of the Fallen journey
across both the land of the living and
the dead using your Lantern to switch
from realm to realm at will this can be
used to unlock hidden areas treasure
hunt and manipulate the very soul of
your foe that's intense Journey Through
the Realms of umbral and Axiom alone or
uninterrupted with friends but be warned
enemy heroes from other Realms can
invade your game in true Dark Souls
fashion Lords of the Fallen is expected
to launch on all consoles in 2023
the next entry in the Dragon Age series
has been teased by BioWare not much is
known about your foe in the next
installment only that his story past
varies greatly depending on who you ask
which side of the story will you fall on
dive into the magic of Dragon Age dread
wolf expected to launch in 2023
and there you go from battles with
ancient monsters to exploring the stars
there is a lot to look forward to for
RPG fans in 2023 let us know if there
are any RPG experiences you're excited
about in the comments I'm Stu and for
everything video games keep it here at
GameSpot